il a remorqué cette voiture brûlée
jusque devant la mairie christophe
paszek garagiste est excédé cette nuit
sa concession a brûlé un incendie
volontaire perpétrée par deux individus
pour faire disparaître cette bmw
accidenté dans une course poursuite avec
la police après un feu de poubelle on
voit deux individus avec enfin cagoulé
qui a pu shawn et qui rend discrètement
dans l'enceinte de notre notre
entreprise
et puis qui met le feu à cette voiture
et puis bon le résultat c'est qu'elle
était au milieu d'autres voitures au
total on a faim nous on a treize
véhicules brûlés dans l'enceinte de
notre entreprise est en tout sur le
montceau-les-mines bassin minier c'est
environ une petite vingtaine de voitures
qui a brûlé cette nuit autour de
christophe une cinquantaine d'habitants
de montceau ont fait le déplacement pour
dénoncer l'insécurité ambiante et
interpeller la municipalité watts au
moins tu as j'ai jamais faire dormir
parce que j'avais peur de retrouver la
voiture brûlée jeune étudiant vous
croyez que j'ai les moyens d'envoyer le
ton monte et les actes de malveillance
se multiplient cinq incendies
volontaires ont été recensés la nuit
dernière dans différents quartiers de la
ville
face à la colère la mairie se dit
impuissante un surveille abl ça on ne
peut pas à moins d'en lever toutes les
poubelles
toutes les poubelles et tout et brossac
et un certain nombre de jeunes de très
jeunes qui ont été arrêtées ni en centre
éducatif fermé
je vous rappelle qu'on ne peut pas
incarcéré alors j'entends bien il faut
incarcéré etc etc mais quand il s'agit
de jeunes entre 14 et 15 ans on ne peut
pas incarcéré une réponse qui attise la
défiance des résidents en proie à la
peur certains préfèrent témoigner à
visage caché
quand je suis dans les rues bas je me
méfie quoi gdr la cua des voitures on a
peur qui nous arrive quelque chose on a
peur pour nos enfants
entre les voitures les poubelles les
aménagements la voirie tout le monde
rame à ce qu a fait des années que ça
dure
souvent nous le cache aussi ce que je
vois bien que
je parle avec des gens qui tuent
montceau et du creusot c'est pas un
effet nouveau il dénonce une délinquance
passer sous silence et nous emmènent
constaté l'épreuve des méfaits ils ont
mis le feu à l'association trait d'union
ça brûle de façon continue depuis depuis
le début de l'été en fête
juste après le feu vous avez cette
maison-là qui a été la proie des flammes
la dame était piégé a été piégé au rez
de chaussée ne pouvait pas ne pouvait
pas sortir quoi et ça ça a brûlé il ya
400 ans à peu près jusqu'à cinq voitures
brûlées par jour pas moins de dix
incendies recensés sur un rayon de 500
mètres autour du centre ville les
habitants songe désormais à créer une
association pour se protéger et se faire
entendre